get to target breaks you win the
tournament that means the white games
must be what he's looking forward to the
white games are key and uh with that in
mind where you starts with this queen's
pawn there's no queens gambit accepted
today so actually this is interesting
level neronian has completely changed
his opening strategy he's gone back to a
more solid uh type of repertoire what
he's been playing since he was a child
basically love neroni we see the nimzo
indian defense and this variation um i
think it's called the samish and white's
pawn structure now ruined
but white has got the bishop pair and
will have the opportunity to build a big
pawn center this is really topical a lot
of the kind of elite players are
fighting out this type of position right
now
black's kind of flexibility solid
structure against white's dynamism of
the pawn center look at white center
it's beautiful here but there is a
weakness on the c4 square white's
doubled sea pawns and black is going for
those guys immediately
this is going to be a big opening battle
oh who has studied their nimso indian
defense more deeply this last bishop
move
i mean i'm not 100 familiar with all the
different move orders here i must admit
there's so many i mean for example with
white you could have brought a knight
out first you could bring a bishop out
first you could push a couple of pawns
with black also you could have castled
the king early on you could have pushed
some pawns in the center both sides have
so many options on every single move
yeah and
just checking my database i can see that
levon aronian has actually played this
position with the black pieces once
before against magnus carlsen himself in
a blitz game in san luis now his
hometown and that game ended in a draw
so i think lavon will be feeling pretty
confident and he goes for the same
formula just uh controlling white center
by advancing a small pawn forward and
then he's getting gonna get ready to
attack one of those weak pawns and uh we
did well actually simon asked wei yi
to play directly to go for the throat
and this is exactly what way he is doing
and we have the mean girls the mean
girls girls yeah four
and yeah it's at least clear what way he
wants to do he wants to throw all the
pawns forward he could even throw the
white jeep on forward potentially at
some point have a five pawn structure
there yeah maybe maybe a bit weakening
but
i think didn't it found sokolov um right
very good book on this opening and uh
one of the advantages of um being a
commentator is you get to see lots of
openings which you wouldn't necessarily
see or play and uh i you know i haven't
really seen this opening from a white
perspective but i'm kind of looking at
and i'm thinking yeah this is the kind
of thing i would play you know because
you've got all those pawns they can
start an attack at some moment and put
your pieces behind them uh exactly what
way he is doing and it's a nice
aggressive setup so i'm actually
thinking yeah this this is certainly an
opening which i could play we're now
going to see black uh grab one of those
bishops and i think this is a clever
move trying to trying to get a focal
point um in the center of the board
trying to hold the center uh before
white takes it over
and this must all be i i'd imagine
ivanka uh it's gonna be well-known it's
been played before i mean two games in
the database but i imagine this is very
thematic
because as you mentioned black has to
take some control in the center
otherwise he's just going to get
steamrolled as you mentioned and here
we've now reached a point where no more
games in my database hasn't been
analyzed before so uh well the players
are now going to start uh freestyling
yeah and interesting last move from wei
yi he's just offered up a pawn sacrifice
actually and the position could look
very much like a king's gambit if black
does accept the sacrifice
right now a lot of pressure on black
central pawn this pawn attack three
times uh from white's two pawns here and
from the white knight so you have to
give way with this pawn somehow why not
grab a pawn in the process
and uh yeah this looks very much like a
king's gambit where black has an extra
pawn
but the question is can white obtain
activity white needs something now
you're upon down and you have this kind
of long-term weakness of the doubled
pawns on this side of the board so you
need to kind of win in the middle game
any end game is going to go against you
with white and the question is do you
just castle the king or do you push
forward i'm a little bit surprised david
that um
white gave up his dark square bishop as
easily as he did in the game maybe
that's the normal move i don't know the
theory but
i would have wanted to have kept that
bishop uh imagine you had that bishop
now uh in the current position you could
just take the pawn back and you can see
that the kind of really strong piece so
a little bit surprised that uh white
went for this system and it's also a
little bit worrying for way that he's
slowed down now because uh he's
basically there's well you could say a
gambit but he's also lost the pawn i
mean uh has he just i mean
this is not really the point to slow
down because it might be you know if he
hasn't looked to this position before
the game uh that's a worrying sign
because obviously if you sacrifice the
pawn uh in the opening you should you
know this is danger danger you should
really know what you're doing and you
should have done your homework so i'm
kind of thinking okay maybe he has done
his homework he's moved quickly there
yeah but it is surprising i mean if we
just rewind a couple of moves here for
example if you want to play it safe you
could trade a set of pawns and then
bring your knight out
so for example you just protect
everything in the center here you're
never going to be a pawn down but
in the game position if we fast back uh
forward back to the game after black
grabbed this pawn we've seen both sides
castle their kings to safety now it's
not just the fact that you're upon down
with black but
how are you ever going to attack like
simon says without your dart squad
bishop that previously sat in this
square ready to come out
now it's a rook so that sits on this
square instead and how do you ever get
at the black king black's king looks
actually pretty safe right now
you have to start attacking
somehow but i'm struggling to see it
also white does have a weakness in the
center this pawn is a bit vulnerable on
an open line
yes it's a tricky one right because it's
not very clear for how white can
actually move forward so it might be one
of those things like a bow and arrow you
know you retreat the bow just to get it
forward so i'm just thinking maybe the
knight can step backwards to d2 so that
the rook can capture the pawn makes me
very nervous actually to play
material down
i love it
i don't know why it's like that risk
factor you know um but life on the edge
yeah yeah yeah but he's he's played your
move there you've anchored david you
were saying about the attack and well i
suppose if he can't take that pawn of
his rook
his pieces are very good aren't they
there might be some good you know
combined with the light square bishop
opening up so it still seems a bit scary
for black here uh and
um one question for you guys here then
simon with that in mind for example if
black moves the queen white's rook you
said has nice attacking potential now
you swing the rooks across go for this
black knight remove that defender it
looks pretty decent for white but would
you ever get tempted as black to keep
this pawn intact
and defend it
oh there's such a kind of king's gambit
type of defense and you're like go all
in
i wouldn't even dream it wouldn't even
cross my mind i have to say
i i mean the normal move in the king's
gambit against that is just to push push
the opponent yeah this pawn here and you
know that could just really open up
everything towards black's king so i
don't i don't think we're going to see
that are we i mean a bit greedy
yeah so yeah done more surprising things
than that i was just
trying to find a way yeah playing
devil's advocate just trying to keep
this black pawn intact but if he can't
keep it then
where he has his chances
thinking now levon aronian they have
castle so i guess we are out of the
opening but on the subject of
uh have you guys uh heard about the game
show the the chase yeah american yeah
yeah i saw this clip earlier yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was great it was posted at
a clip on reddit from the show so a
question uh the other day on that show
was performed by magnus carlson and
hikaru nakamura in 2021 the double bunk
cloud is a rarely seen maneuver in what
and the contestant i think he answered
uh juggling yeah something like that
yeah yeah but then the expert he said
don't you know who magnus carlson is
he's the highest rated player in the
world so he got it yeah nice very nice i
don't think anyone in norway would would
fail that question would they
everyone knows who magnus is over here
don't know but in england they it's a
little a little bit different so yeah is
it english i thought it was american it
was maybe sure it might be english i
think actually yeah yeah
but it's cool so they had a question
from the champions chester double bond
cloud played last season
we're getting famous yeah
and uh meanwhile levon does touch his g
pawn but doesn't move it too squares
forward instead just makes a little bit
of air for his king but at the same time
potentially weakens the dark squares and
wei yi very quickly
just uh captures that pawn and this was
lavon's idea all along to attack the
rook with his knight yep looks like a
superficial square for the black knight
but at least he gains a bit of time the
black knight was maybe a target where
where it previously stood anyway so
white's rook will take a couple of steps
back now and
just depends what levon wants to do next
maybe bring the black queen out yep well
i think we are looking at some exciting
games and is the final day of the
tournament and also
the tour final for these two and so you
know that means a lot of excitement a
lot of adventure and we love it when you
at home get involved and join in on the
fun and action so we are once again
having a selfie competition how are you
watching the tour we want to see those
photos
remember to take them in landscape mode
and use the hashtag chesschamps and we
will feature them on the show and
today's prize is one year's chess 24
premium membership
so remember hashtag chess champs we want
to see the selfies we want the more
interesting the better and we love it
absolutely and uh also we should remind
everyone that we are having a little bit
of a challenge yeah how many grand
masters can you name in 30 seconds yes
and
if you want to get in on the fun there
then you also can tweet us using the
hashtag chessjams and also cryptocup
challenge it's uh not so easy as uh some
of us found out yesterday so ivanka
who's going to be tested today i mean
like carya put me on the spot
[Laughter]
someone's it can't just be me who's on
the spot someone's got to have a go but
remember the challenge it goes on for
the whole ftx summer of chess okay so
maybe that sounds like a cop-out
i must admit i was pre-warned that simon
was going to be tested and that was
i
[Laughter]
very average i
think all right well you didn't mention
any of these to weigh or live on ironian
and now it's wei yi thinking for over
two minutes on this move
he played very fast in the openings
yesterday but is this one this opening
is it is it more difficult harder to
maneuver
possibly i guess there's just a lot of
choice we talked about earlier both
sides being really flexible but then a
few exchanges happened and
maybe the positions become a bit more
concrete now you have to be a bit more
accurate first i guess where ye has to
just remove his rook uh from the firing
line the black knight on the edge of the
board is attacking it
and uh maybe if we jump in we can have a
vote where do we think this rook is
going to move to it's attacked
simon do you think it's going to retreat
first of all
uh yeah i mean i wanted to push it one
square forwards but i mean
that is just like a bit too much um so i
i expect
um
yeah this idea dave is showing just but
i don't think this is this is anything
at all really maybe the black queen just
comes out slides across uh if white
doesn't take this pawn yeah also the
question is
you're attacking maybe you don't even uh
yeah it doesn't really do anything so i
expect the rook to
personally go back two squares um so i
got the option of doubling my rooks on
the half open file um that that to me
looks the most natural
and i expect her onions ideas to bring
the queen out but i think i'd put the
rook there just or maybe even the square
in front of it yeah because then it can
swing over and we know how much i love a
bit of swinging with my roof as i say
just clarify that just in case there's
anyone wandering there
but yeah the swinging brook um so that's
also another option but that does go
into the line of the bishop so um so i
don't know that's the way i'd be
thinking david anyway yeah my vote is
for the that square actually as well
because i think that if black is tempted
to open up the position that's probably
going to favor white because he needs to
initiate some activity some dynamism he
wants that fire on the board and more
chances for lavon to go wrong and i also
quite like this
rook wrote i'm going to call it a roving
rook swinging as well no i'm not going
to say that
rick
rick roller or rook no they're rick
roller's the incorrect rookover rook
over rover rover rover yeah
that's the one so yeah i'm going to be
difficult and i'm going to vote for this
square so i don't think we'll bet on
this it's not the most critical move
yeah but uh it is surprising to see
where you spend look at that nearly five
minutes just deciding on where to put
his rook you definitely don't want to
put it back the whole way because then
you get in the way of this rook kind of
joining on this square so it would just
be logical step back one square or two
squares
is he really considering stepping
forward going for this night maybe but
it's not really worth spending five
minutes
on this kind of thing where black isn't
even forced to capture and uh kind of
take the sacrifice anyway
this is this is one of the problems i
think where ye showed yesterday right i
mean he he he in quite obvious positions
his rook's attacked you move it right
yeah he was spending too long and that
later on when he got these winning
positions
he wasn't able to convert them because
he'd used up all his time so i i don't
this is i don't know why he's doing it
here you know i was would have thought
he'd learnt from
the mistakes yesterday because it is
quite an obvious position really yeah
it's like you said there will be
consequences maybe in 30 moves time from
the
five six minutes that he's spent now
and uh a more experienced player like
levon or magnus carlsen or kind of what
the top players in the world they would
just play according to their instincts
retreat one square retreat two squares
whatever they're both fine and then the
critical moments will be ahead
i mean this is where i would also waste
maybe two three minutes on the clock but
i don't think i would be spending six
minutes on this one retreat yeah i mean
it does seem very impractical i have a
question for both of you do you think
that this is an effect of uh wei yi
perhaps
playing so early in the morning and the
tournament of course late at night yes
yeah like is it is it not early morning
at the minute
one of the two isn't it
i guess it depends how you don't call it
in the morning if you haven't gone to
sleep you've just woken up right yeah
yeah yeah okay late at night late at
night in the i always say in the early
hours of the morning yeah midnight or
definitely nighttime
i rarely go to sleep before midnight so
to me to me it's
to me it's late night if you're saying
earlier of the morning it's like dawn
when the sun's coming up i mean the
sun's gone down for a while it's
definitely when does it shift from night
to morning for you david yeah at what
time morning starts at 1pm or
that's a chess play this morning
i would say like 6
5 a.m maybe 5 a.m is morning everything
before that is late night early hours in
the mornings anything up to 10 a.m like
yeah
for me early hours in the morning like
like 1 1 a.m 1 a.m to 3 3 four a.m and
then it just becomes morning and then
yeah
i don't know what the hell is going on
at the moment
i'm just sitting here dazed and cooking
someone's got a very strange dictionary
out there
yeah i'm sure i'm incorrect but uh
that's the that's my
i guess it's the kind of thing if you're
early but i'm always
exactly right i think it depends if
you're an early bird or if you like to
stay up at night yeah that makes a
difference i'm gonna become an even
earlier bird actually oh because you
know obviously david and myself are
going to india and they're ahead in time
and we actually had pragnanda and
everyone talking about how they adjusted
their hours in order to
to train for competitions and i will be
doing the same so it won't be six a.m in
the morning it will be five oh
when will games go why why would you do
that to yourself
this is like what normal people do david
you go you do like office jobs and stuff
and a lot of people do this you know
chess games at 3 p.m yeah because i was
going to ask when will the game start
3pm yeah yeah but there will be three
hours ahead
but that means you'd be waking up uh
what i mean three and a half hours ahead
nine nine and that's 39. even that's
risky
i think you've been awake i think you've
got to do what you have i mean i i used
to be a night person but now now i'm a
morning person so you're able to
actually turn it around yeah i'd
probably start at night and get up early
to be honest but i mean yeah i think
it's it's just what suits you really
isn't it and um you know if you're a
morning person clearly vancouver and
imagine you're a night person david
definitely yesterday
um yeah but it's important to get the
right routine in tournament or whatever
you're doing yeah but i mean going back
to wei yi playing nine minutes playing
at this time yeah i mean first of all
why is he taking so long it's just crazy
at this point he's probably going to
play a bad move because he's
overthinking what should be a relatively
simple position it's crazy super simple
i think this is a record in the tour i
mean thinking for nine minutes yeah i'm
not even in a complicated position it
doesn't make any sense to me the only
thing i can be thinking of is he must
therefore be looking at a crazy move
because otherwise you just move the roof
um but him playing at this time i was
thinking that but he's the one and he's
played a normal move he's the one who's
been uh prolonging
the games anyway and if he was tied you
would have thought he'd make the game
shorter so that that's a bit of a
surprise okay david they banged out some
moves here yeah i mean very natural
moves again uh black's queen did indeed
come out as we uh suggested and after
white's rooks doubled up now on this f
file black's remaining rook in the
corner has swung to a very
nice square white's queen feels a bit
uncomfortable on this open on this kind
of semi-open e file big pressure on
white's pawn center
where ye again very natural move i mean
these are the first moves that come to
his mind so he could have this exact
same position with nine extra minutes on
the clock
it's
nervous it must be something not
trusting his instincts
maybe he was calculating a simon said a
bit of a weird move and then he decided
against it but
in classical chess when you have two
hours on your clock you have that luxury
you can kind of fall down the rabbit
hole a few times and get carried away
calculating variations but rapid chest
is a completely different type of animal
you need to save that nine minutes for
later and
if this game is decided a bit like
yesterday in the time scramble or were
ye not having enough time on the clock
we can pinpoint that one moment we'll
say okay it was move 17 where he spent
nine minutes
and uh he would love to have that one
moment back again what's the most you
spent on a move david i mean because
obviously you love easily you love your
deep things to understand the position
and it works very well for you so uh but
over an hour right over and over and
over wow wow yeah i've done that early
in the career wouldn't timed them it was
different i think it i think is a nice
thing to do but and ivanka you can
roughly have you ever done over an hour
no i don't think so um
but i mean i do remember and i hate to
bring up bad memories for you simon but
i do remember an hourglass game we
played played a very unusual time
control where it was like one and a half
hours for all our moves with some added
time and i remember there was one point
where i could have sacrificed and i saw
that there was a sacrifice but i was
like this is not practical i'm gonna
have to navigate things i'm going to
have to burn a lot of time on my clock
in order just to make sure that the
sacrifice is sound and i was like no i'm
going to play something else that gives
that i know is going to give me an
advantage and uh yeah crush me
oh
i was thinking also just a nice story
about
bronstein
he was playing he's very famous player
david bronstein and maybe you've met you
guys have met him because he played in
hastings
quite a lot he was maybe one of the
strongest players never become world
champion uh he had a close match with
bottomic we see another move here just
the queen going forwards with some night
jump ideas but in hastings they have a
game on the it starts on the first of
january and uh he was playing on the
first january and he was sitting there
with the white pieces
and um
move one
and he just sat there for like 55
minutes on move one yeah on move one and
and he was like everyone was like what's
he doing he's just sitting there and
move one he hasn't played one move what
so he obviously won a lovely game i say
obviously he's very strong and someone
says well what do you think what are you
thinking of and he goes well it's start
of a new year i wanted to start the year
good and i felt like i felt like i
should bring a night out
so it's like i felt like you know get
the knights out that feels right better
than bringing a pawn out so he's just
he's just thinking how he wanted to
start his year so he's like drifting off
and he decided to bring a night out
because he thought that was a more funky
way to start yeah i thought that's quite
nice actually i thought yeah did you
know bronstein on the subject of that he
was famous for doing this actually uh i
mean his teammates hated him because you
know he'd play for the soviet union and
he'd do a simon says turn up
sit there and think for 20 minutes on
the first move and the teammates were
like
just get going and of course he always
found himself in time travel as well
and uh it's kind of a little bit
unforgivable i think
although i do like that stories yeah
yeah yes
well no way he is definitely spending
time taking down to three minutes will
this be dramatic for him back in the
tank and the best he can come up with is
an exchange of queens he's just dropped
his knight back where it came from
just on the last move and he's trying to
get the queens off the board but this
can only favor black surely if you look
at white's pawn structure again white
has an isolated a pawn long-term factor
black or white has doubled c pawns also
a long-term factor and
those will kind of add up in black's
favor once the queen's disappeared from
the board maybe there was just nothing
better maybe he had to do this because
there was some serious pressure on white
center anyway and black's knight was
also threatening to maybe jump into the
position but
yeah having spent all that time and
having to play a move that doesn't
really favor you strategically it's uh
that's not a good sign for you maybe a
draw off a date as well here because
okay erodia's not taking the draw but
how do you step back with a queen then
we could have seen a repetition how can
one take advantage of this so he has
much more time on the clock it seems
like we is a little nervous he is
thinking a lot in this game how can
levon take advantage and maybe go for
the win in this game uh he will try and
go for the win but he won't be able to
do that anytime soon he'll have to
slowly build up i mean the advantages
that black has here they are very long
term
as we mentioned the a pawn isolated that
could be a target for maybe the black
knight or black rooks later on um these
pawns are maybe more of a direct target
for example not expecting it right now
but in the near future black could fix
these pawns by pushing his own pawn
forward these guys are never ever moving
again and then slowly but surely for
example you can bring a bishop to the
edge of the board put some pressure on
this diagonal you could swing a black
rook across uh try and force white to
close the center if white closes the
center white's pieces lose a lot of
dynamism also if you just look at the
white pawns right now they look very
nice they control a lot of squares but
remember with great space comes great
responsibility and white's pieces are
actually tied down defending especially
this pawn writes rook is passive
defending it white's bishop is passive
uh defending it and white's knight also
passive defending um whoops defending
this pawn as well so
yeah it does feel like levon for example
he can start by just improving his
pieces he can step one rook forward step
the other rook behind put even more
pressure on this pawn white's pawns here
they cannot really step forward without
creating even more weaknesses as well so
targets here black's knight at some
point i expect it to kind of drop back
and re-route itself into the center
maybe in conjunction with this pawn move
i mentioned
it's just a whole bunch of ideas for
black and what's white doing in the
meantime maybe white will start pushing
forward on this side of the board
gaining some space there but no real
targets and no attack ever with the
queen's off
if i could have this position with the
queen's back on the board where black's
queen was passive then he'd be happy but
that's why level on iranian went so
active with the black queen
and why we saw the queens disappear
right now it's
in my eyes at least it's kind of only
live on who can hope
uh to have an advantage in this type of
position but of course all of those
plans i was highlighting they're quite
long term they're quite slow
so it's still a while before levon can
claim anything too big
before we can get too excited
yeah
but i have to say you know we saw
several times where you shake his head
he's not happy with his position he
knows that he is going to suffer and
this is not good news
and uh whilst uh levon is concerned what
no i spoke too soon the bishop does take
a step backwards um
that was a little bit surprising to me i
didn't expect that move
and uh well i was just going to share
with you a few selfies because we are
running a selfie competition and it's
super exciting and uh there we see lavon
just
not live on uh where you excuse me
double the rocks on the open line and uh
rafa sean is cheering for aronian he
says right from brazil big fan
and uh we also have a selfie from
reltnape who
says watching while cleaning the kitchen
so it's not the only one cleaning just
like lavon not exciting but with a brand
new baby you have to multitask all the
times congratulations definitely yeah
and uh finally rob durham is watching
the show and enjoying a new tv oh so uh
there there we see we are on the big
screen yeah and david and simon and uh
okay let's see some uh let's get back to
the game yeah those rooks are they
dangerous two works in the same line
they look nice and pretty but everything
they're attacking i mean they're only
eyeing up a pawn right now and that pawn
is well fortified well defended
i mean i like that move for white but i
don't really see what's next um we were
kind of slightly confused by the idea of
black's bishop retreat black bishop
going back to its start square i guess
the idea is just to stop white's pawns
on the king side advancing forward
for example black's knight on the edge
of board of the board could have been
attacked by a white pawn but black's
bishop from afar covers any potential
white pawn advances
the question is again what next for
levon iranian i would just lift up
black's rook on the e file one square
there we go just to defend the pawn that
uh the white rooks are looking at uh-huh
and also pretending maybe
uh or hinting at the fact that the black
rooks might stack up on the e-file
towards white central ports i think i
heard you say before david you want to
protect your pieces or your pawns three
times yeah if three times and then
they're nearly always safe
if if you can achieve that so black's f7
pawn that the white rooks were looking
at was
not a weakness at all if a pawn is
defended twice occasionally there'll be
a sacrifice on that square or someone
can break through on that square but
yeah protect it three times and
no chance of trouble okay
now black's knight can jump in what do
we think about this last night move by
wei
um i i think he's stuck for a plan to be
honest so he just made a random move and
i agree with you the knight can jump in
i mean but the question is
what else is the knight going to do i
mean is it going to perhaps take a step
back
go to the e6 square and then
just go on a few more adventures until
it finds the perfect location
or
i mean the black knight is not on the
perfect location right now so i would uh
it's tempting isn't it just to put it to
attack the bishop and maybe you can
actually ask some questions as to how
white is going to defend
one of those double pawns yup
of those white double sea pawns it's
always the one in front that's the first
target so that pawn could become a
target for the black bishop later but
levon i mean he doesn't look fully
focused right now he was looking away
for a while
he doesn't look as energetic as we saw
yesterday when he it was just when he
got a small advantage it was bang bang
bang the moves were coming
fast
yeah and he's getting a bit short of
time as well here i mean yeah he seems
he does catch it so i do notice the top
players where they spend most time in a
chess game is always when it's the
planning phase
with the calculation even if it's quite
complicated calculation they can do it
very quickly because they structure
their thoughts they look at the checks
the captures the threats bang bang bang
two three four moves they can see into
the future but when there's no forced
reply for their opponent
they're thinking oh i could maneuver my
knight to this square i can move into my
knight to my bishop to this square but
in the meantime the opponent has four or
five moves and then it's kind of a
slower process of
thinking he's still got that dodgy light
isn't it yeah i just noticed it yeah
sort it out and wei has been looking a
lot up in the air
what does that mean again david when
they look up to
normally if they look up kind of top
left it means they're remembering
something if they look just straight up
it's like ugh
why where's the inspiration
some inspiration
um if they look right it often means
they're kind of
bluffing normally or like they're kind
of like trying to work something out
um i think the memory at least is the
left side okay usually it's very
interesting
yeah i've always seen hikaru he's always
looking up
at the ceiling yeah i think he's yeah
with hikaru you never know because half
of it is kind of reaction of course like
all chess players half is maybe a
performance yeah
but i mean all the top players they have
these kind of little quirks little
habits i mean it's part of the game as
well right play the psychological game
as well
yeah and uh levon well his time is also
ticking down now he's under four minutes
on the clock i mean he has plenty of
time but he has to come to a decision
soon and
he steps back with his knight we were
talking about the knight jumping forward
and uh well he's going to attack the
pawn on e4 yeah i feel that this um
maybe this is a draw offer
oh
as in the white knight might drop back i
don't know why i keep trying to find a
draw
clearly loving this position yeah i mean
i i agree that black is probably better
and aronian won't take a draw if he's
better so but i mean again if the white
knight goes back then the black knight
has to move again
um i can't see any so but maybe he's
doing away maybe he's just repeating
positions just to see the knight's just
dancing show his boss as well yeah um
yeah i mean i don't think why it's okay
this is this is interesting where he has
he's gone straight forwards yeah so not
playing for the draw this pawn was
attacked
going forward
and what's level i'm going to do here if
you trade off this pawn then suddenly it
does look a bit scary white's night now
on a great central square and these
rooks
have targets the black knight has to
move uh maybe you could swap off the
black knight now for the white knight
maybe this is what levon is banking on
if the knights disappear still minimal
danger for black these pawns aren't
great either long term
but
yeah big decision if you don't take this
pawn then the only real option is to go
back with the knight i guess you could
jump forward but uh the thing is here
you're attacking the white rook you have
to deal with a counter attack pawn takes
pawn hitting the black rook
it suddenly gets a bit complicated maybe
black just keeps it simple though and
takes the pawn back and it's about
whether this pawn is a weakness it's an
isolated pawn now
okay levon doesn't want to deal with
that kind of issue
bit surprising he spent all that time on
a non-forcing move and then played quite
a forcing move quite quickly
and okay as predicted he's trying to get
the knights off the board so double
attack hitting the rook and the white
knight
i'm expecting white now to just
capture the knights and
the only option here i guess is to try
and counter attack against the black
rook but no that's too flashy take the
knights off the board is what way ye is
thinking and teamwork as well i think
yeah pre-moved by level iranian he took
back the knight here automatically
because it was a safe pre-move uh we see
a safe pre-move because black's bishop
landing on the square would never ever
happen unless black's knight was taken
so you don't want to pre-move something
that you know your opponent could win
some material but here it's only legal
bishop to g4 if
the white knight captures
i think you said there was a dramatic
pre-move
in the preliminaries was it wary antare
yeah uh i mentioned aryantari he had
three legal moves in the position he was
in check but he'd pre-moved the only
losing move
uh to capture a pawn when actually his
king should have just run away anywhere
safe from the check and it would have
been a draw
so you really have to be sure before
pre-moving
and that cost him he was so close to
qualification yeah
and now okay i think wei is trying to
get a draw now by just swapping off all
the rooks
it's definitely only black who can be
better here just because
these three uh pawns are not very
flexible they're not very mobile as we
say uh the pawns if they step forward uh
this pawn for example uh stepping
forward that would just ruin white's
pawn structure this one would ruin the
dark squares so we do see a trade
and
the black rook get active
it has the problem for levon ironian is
can you advance these three to beat
white two on this side of the board can
you get the black king active
how do you target white's weaknesses
here and here
not easy still a lot of work to be done
but you guys who would you take
lavon's position i mean i had completely
forgotten that black had a poor majority
on that side so when you mentioned that
plan i was like oh yes of course
uh yeah i just utilized that extra pawn
there and as a bonus
just try to also keep some eye
contact with the weak pawns you know try
to do everything at once i mean i i like
levon's position and uh i think he will
he has the time
he has the incentive so he's playing for
the win yeah you know
this is a dream position to grind out
okay if you don't manage to do anything
great your opponent defended well but if
you manage just to put a pressure on
your opponent and bearing in mind wei yi
has just over two and a half minutes on
the clock not that much time
for many of us so why not he said a
nasty trap as well there's a big threat
on the board bishop takes porn is
actually a threat
right now because for example the white
king is suddenly overworked it wants to
take the black bishop but it would lose
control over the white bishop so black
would have won a pawn in the process
that being said white actually stopped
this threat by pushing a pawn in the
center and levon has actually lost two
moves he moved his bishop forward and
then he moved it back again where it
came from but he's provoked white's pawn
forward onto a light square and this is
relevant because now if the rooks
disappear then black's king has a clear
path on the dark squares into the
position
so watch out for that kind of maneuver
happening a bit later on um
because white's paul has stepped forward
he's lost the integrity of his pawn
structure lost all control over the dark
squares but where he has a specific idea
in mind by bringing his rook across now
to stop this idea of the king coming
forward i think he wants to just step
his pawn forward with a sacrifice and
get his rook into the game
this is how a lot of the top chinese
players play actually they try to solve
strategic problems with tactics and with
dynamism and sacrificing a pawn here
would be i think actually a great thing
for white
so a small mini threat pushing the pawn
forward maybe this is one level missed
or underestimated at least
a very crafty move indeed and uh that we
see
levon thinking
do you think uh
i was gonna ask her do you think
levon will uh burn extra time on his
clock just to deal with this or will he
just kind of continue as normal and just
go well
it is what it is well done
yeah i i don't think he wants to allow
that white pawn from advancing um really
and it seems like
white could uh
even get a better position i i feel if
that pawn goes up so if i if i was live
i'd be thinking of even stopping that by
moving my pawn two squares but that that
comes with a lot of risk as well uh it
changes the nature the strategic nature
of the the game because uh i you know i
clamp down on those white pawns in the
center so the double pawns become very
weak but i give white a very powerful
past pawn uh protected past pawn that's
only three squares from queening but
i'll be thinking along this way maybe i
could even also push that pawn one
square uh as well maybe uh do do
something like this
um but i wouldn't really want to allow
my you know my opponent if i was left to
do the plan that he wants to do one it's
never really good to allow your opponent
to a plan and two
it just looks like a good plan so i need
to you know i'd rather stop it if i can
somehow i mean there's other natural
moves here as well i'm sure but uh
you know i think this is a very good
very good plan from where ye actually
yeah this pawn push does look pretty
menacing i guess there are other ways
maybe you could put your rook in the
center of the board keep an eye on this
guy or you could maybe uh sorry after
white moved his rook across uh rather
the black rook coming up you could
first hit the white rook he has done
this and put your bishop in the center
of the board i guess just to guard this
pawn
so just preventing white from stepping
the pawn next to it up the board he
would lose the central pawn if he does
that i'm thinking that a bishop exchange
here i'm looking at rook exchanges
bishop exchanges i think a rook exchange
bishop exchange would favor white in
general but in this exact situation
getting the bishops off the board would
definitely approve the black rook
so
maybe in this exact scenario this is
something levon ironian can try
but
for example if he parks his bishop in
the middle of the board okay which he
has just done
now there is this clear plan remember of
the black king coming in and
what can white do
if white trades the bishops maybe that
favors black if white trades the rooks
ever that definitely favors black
because black will control the dark
squares
i don't really see any kind of exchanges
that save white at the moment
yeah it's a question of timing isn't it
and
yeah white will have to start doing some
active operations and there he goes with
the apron
and he's intending to soften up black's
pawn structure there on the left
and there's nothing that levon can do so
he just returns to the original plan
which is just to bring the king to the
center
yep it would make a lot of sense at
least for white to trade off the a pawn
for one of black's pawns because that is
an isolated pawn after all it sits on
the light square now so you can't keep
it there any longer
why is where you thinking he started a
plan you have to be consistent with it
before it's too late
just push that a pawn forward again
it's a temporary pawn sacrifice but if
the b file comes open for white's rook
that would be fantastic so
snap that board forward yeah it just
seems to be overthinking things a little
bit weighty doesn't he a little bit
nervous in this first game
which you know and also you can't you
can't move this slowly when you've got
one minute uh 20 seconds left they've
both got one minute one and a half
minutes basically
uh let's position looks quite nice to me
i mean that that king
as you pointed out it's just coming in
on the dark squares so so i think i
think something like this is the right
idea if i was white here i'd try to swap
off pieces swap off pawns
make some exchanges get nearer to a draw
so uh i mean the danger of this move is
black's rook now gets in and and having
an active rook is really important in
brook endings bar is going up for lavon
and you did say that this would look
good for the black
side that's the thing simon's right in
general a bishop bishop exchange does
help white just because the rook end
games have this kind of george tendency
in kind of in general but in this exact
sit uh situation the black rook is so
active but he has to go c5 here i mean
that's two sets of pawns yeah yeah c5
then you've got ideas of moving the pawn
next to that so i mean that if he if he
stay if he goes passive here he's in
loads of trouble i think black's king
gets two moves to move into the center
yeah as you mentioned game over yeah the
problem is that black's work has gone
rogue
and
now you need to start calculating yes uh
he's played the poor move and this is
the move that i was thinking levon would
play attack upon
and uh again threaten to initiate chaos
because every single time
where ye will be considering what's
going to happen after pawn takes pawn
yeah
i suppose the good thing for wei yi if
you if you he's got four pawns on the
queen side the left-hand side black's
got three pawns if he loses a pawn on
that area of the board but not able to
swap off all the pawns it's a draw so if
you just see where the kings are
black you know if you're just dealing
with those pawns and nothing else and
that side of the board it's not enough
to win rook endings have very often
drawn so maybe that could be something
that is going to save wei yi uh later on
maybe i agree
just uh if he can manage those exchanges
but they're both now getting under a
minute
so it's uh and here we see the first uh
exchange happen black king's still
coming in though isn't it that black
king is still
stepping in but do we think white's rook
has to go active now
absolutely
definitely go active i think now yeah
yeah
i mean just abandon everything just
white's rook has to get to the seventh
rank take your chance now exactly gamble
create some passports and uh he's done
that so he's actually two pawns down
currently where ye but the white king is
suddenly super active and the white rook
is super active so that's a good in-game
idea yeah
and a very interesting move from
the chinese player because here if if
levon were to get super greedy and go
for a third porn well actually white's
pawn in the middle of the board is going
to be a strong one it's only three
squares away from queening and it will
have the assistance of the rook and the
king in its uh promotion
hopes this odd from levon aronian he's
just given up a pawn with check but he
has got the black king active
temporarily
so white has options here white has two
pawns he could capture the
a pawn the f-pawn or he could just slide
back the white rook one square and check
back the black king
it's confusing here right i mean these
voices yeah
i mean
you give the check i think given the
czech's good uh i you know to try and
force black king to a worse square right
yeah because if black gets time to step
the black rook back one square and check
the white king white's king is the one
forced
backwards
i mean i'm just really surprised what
levon's done to be honest i think he
could have played for a win in a far
safer way now it's just
you could lose this one couldn't because
that white board in the center of the
board is so strong
uh if the white rook can now get active
maybe going uh to the left hand side uh
you know like like he's played now i
mean this is this is uh
we saw we saw something similar didn't
we in another game i think it was
yesterday where it was just that one
pawn that white had was so scary and it
it won the game for i think it won the
game for someone but i think this is
great defensive uh technique from levon
and i think he's doing this but other
also at the same time kind of keeping
that draw in the pocket because now that
uh white pawn in the middle doesn't have
the aid of its king so he could if he
wanted to bail out could just give uh
start attacking the pawn in the middle
yeah yeah maybe this is what's going to
happen now um
we could yeah see those exchanges i'm
also feeling the heat a little bit if i
were playing black i would be like okay
just bail out now this feels like it's
gone wrong
why has gotten too active definitely
lost control as iranian but uh he is
currently a porn up so okay going for
white's g2 pawn now on the second rank
that's slightly surprising i've got to
say
he's just kind of making a useful
waiting move i guess
so again as you guys mentioned if that
black apron falls as soon as the white
rook leaves the sixth rank black's king
comes into the center
so where ye also waits and just offers a
porn trade
probably very sensible the more pawns
that disappear the closer you are to a
draw lots of pawns getting exchanged off
right and you know that
you you have to say the draw is very
likely at the moment just because
there's not gonna be many pawns left
on the board it feels like a huge missed
opportunity for levon i think he
initiated all these forcing moves just
one move too soon
yeah i just i'm thinking back to a
previous position and i think black's
king could have gotten much more active
than it currently is but uh wait one
second here i mean suddenly the white
king has taken a step back it's lost
kind of coordination with the pawn and
the rook
and i feel that this is
okay no i stand corrected uh lavonna has
decided to repeat moves the king is back
on the fourth row okay but black's rook
is on a new square now so can blacks get
greedy go and capture white's h-porn
maybe yep
oh i i'm not sure about this position
anymore i mean it's getting wild
who are you uh liking it for then
um i have to say i'm liking it for lavon
okay but at the same time i feel that
way yes king and rook are so active
that uh it probably will end in a draw
it's just really instructive in general
what way you did he gave up two pawns he
was two pawns down for a while but he
just went active with his king and rook
compare it to a few moves before when
white's king and rook were passive
it was level material but he was
suffering uh so i think that's a lesson
for everyone at home and one that
i mean we'll uh take away from this game
active surely a draw now isn't this the
third time or it's the second time we've
seen the second time so if he goes check
here it'll be a draw no but he's gone
for it he's taking the pawn
and uh okay he's using the strategy of
repeating position twice
teasing us and then playing for the win
well he did say that he wanted to take
inspiration from the youngsters and i
guess that's what he's doing
yeah the problem for black is again two
pawns up but look at the black pawns
they're all isolated they're not
connected one by one they should start
to drop that's the first one and white
sprigs seems to be an ideal square there
as well i mean you can always grab a
pawn at any moment it cuts the black
king off
white central pawn is very good so i i
again this still seems like pretty dead
draw to me
really look at lavon he just leaned back
he realizes now that the winning chances
have pretty much disappeared it's still
a good result for him a draw we're going
to say he's black yeah sure he only
needs two out of four today so it's when
was when he moved his rook in and he
could have moved his king in was maybe
the
slight missed opportunity but we kind of
look at it yeah later anyway quite
possibly yeah
but uh yeah okay he's running with one
pawn
is harry gonna win the day do you think
simon no no not in this one i don't
think so
i think i think white's
i mean
how how's white gonna do it i don't know
um
could you i mean i'd like to get my king
bit more centralized but there's
annoying check because if i can move my
the white king one square to the left
then
i'm threatening some
very strong moves there so he has he's
kind of moved it diagonally so it can't
be checked
and now there's just a fret of the
petrol check with the white rook
and well they're only going to have two
pawns each anyway so i mean
just can't see this being
lasting much longer really yeah and
these rook spawns so the a and h pawns
uh in some end games for example night
end games they're so powerful but in
rook end games they're just so easy to
stop
and levon aronian there we go shaking
his head i think we'll see the draw
happen now
pretty much white's rook we'll just go
and grab a pawn it actually has a couple
of pawns to choose it takes the most
obvious pawn and okay levon's king moves
once rick will just find any safe square
he could push the pawn no he can't oh no
he can't he can't that would be a trap
yeah i can't get clever here where his
rook is attacked this pawn is stepping
forward it looks like white's about to
make a new queen but unfortunately
blackstroke can stop it you can't slide
across yet because white's king covers
that square first you give a check
hitting the king and next move you slide
across and you're just in time to stop
this pawn so okay of course he spots
that way and he doesn't get hasty but
it's a threat now maybe to push forward
levon should really force the draw now
though yeah just before it's too late
yeah and uh he only has 22 seconds on
the clock and uh he has 12
10 nine it's sticking down whose pawn is
faster
the answer is neither
white's rook just stops this pawn okay
small trap here for
levon
uh that he set on wei if this pawn was
captured we would see a check and
suddenly after a rook trade this black
pawn does win the day it's impossible to
stop ah so that was a small trap but we
of course spotted that as well these
guys are too good to fall into one with
blunders he drops his rook back and uh
now after this move i'm expecting to see
the white pawn start pushing forward
this will act as as a distraction and uh
white's rook will meanwhile gobble up
one or both of these pawns
okay the pawn pushes forward as david's
indicated and uh well the race is kicked
off but it is a race that probably will
just really result in trades
i've but it's making me nervous actually
watching them run down the clock so much
and uh
yeah i know he keeps surprising us at
every turn just when we think it is a
draw he makes a different type of move
and the game continues you have to be
really careful of the way you now you
have to get your rook behind that black
h pawn it's two squares away
yeah suddenly it's a bit more
complicated it should still be a draw of
course
the pawns can be stopped by the
opponent's rooks
but way under 10 seconds the whole time
playing with fire yeah but now we're
going to see it
well is this so clear i mean yeah
probably probably the rook the black
rook is uh his turn to put the rook
behind the past porn and if you play
that isn't black still
though black still seems to be pushing i
mean yeah why didn't we push this pawn a
few moves ago i mean it should still be
a draw maybe but you might win a porn
with black now the kid the black king is
active and white's pieces can't can't do
anything so has he oh i don't think he's
lost on time he may
oh
is he lost on time has he lost on time i
don't think he looks lost on time but
but the bar has he's also gone look at
the bar he's just a pawn what happened
what's going on did he lose on time then
there's nothing that has happened i i
think it's a mouse slip what happened
that how did he mouse live he was just
lost he wanted to defend his pawn ah
what a dramatic finish to the first game
it looks like wei has lost this lavon
aronian taking the lead
oh wow heartbreak for
wei both players they seem a little
confused well way ye seem just
devastated we're confused as well was
that losing on time because he only had
five seconds at the end there
surely he wouldn't resign in a position
like this surely he would at least play
on a few more moves even if he's
blundered
really surprising kind of out of the
middle of nowhere it was just completely
drawn two moves ago
he self-destructed wei yi it was just
the momentous occasion the nerves of a
final
something but levon takes it again
wow a